هذا هذه الفكره تغلغلت في اذهان الناس
وانتشرت بشكل شائع في العالم العربي وما
الذي حدث هذه الجماعات الاسلام السياسي
قامت برسم حاله متخيله للتاريخ حاله
متخيله للتاريخ غير غير موجود يوافق
اهدافهم ورغباته لماذا لماذا صنعوا هذا
الشيء يريد ان يرسموا حاله متخيله للتاريخ
ثم يقولون نحن المعبرين عن هذا التاريخ
نحن من نمثل التاريخ الاسلامي بناء على
هذه الصوره المتخيله ما الذي حدث ما هو
اثار ذلك اثار خطيره جدا على الوعي الجمعي
الجمعي في العالم الاسلامي الذي حدث ان
الناس المتلقين الذين تاثروا بهذا الخطاب
الذي يضخ في الخطب والمواعظ والندوات
والاشرطه والى اخره الذي حدث ان الناس
المتاثرين بهذا الامر ظنوا ان هذا هو
التاريخ الاسلامي او قالوا نعم هذا هو
التاريخ صحيح فظنوا ان التاريخ عباره عن
حاله دينيه مثاليه
ولما تاتي لهم وتقول لا يا جماعه الخير
تراه مو بهذا تاريخنا هذا تاريخنا ليس
بهذا الشكل انت تشوه التاريخ الاسلامي
فصار هناك حاله اختطاف حقيقيه لها لهذا
التاريخ من الجانب اخر هناك ايضا فئات
اخرى رافضه للاسلاميين ورافضه لطرحهم لكن
مع الاسف ايضا ظنوا ان طرحهم للتاريخ
الاسلامي هو هذا هو التاريخ فنفروا ايضا
من تاريخنا قالوا اذا كان هذا التاريخ
الاسلامي فلا نريده صار في كلا الحالتين
حاله انفصال كبيره عن تاريخنا وان اقول
هذه الجنايه فكريه وثقافيه كبيره جدا
لماذا لان تاريخنا وتراثنا هو حق لنا هو
حق لهذه الشعوب العربيه والمسلمه في
العالم الاسلامي حقنا وتراثنا لا يحق لاحد
ان يختطفه ويختزله